everything seems the operational now
rats okay here we go
Frank forest accent and the Seminoles
come in at twenty nine and seven inside
with the ice dump Chris come on g4 -
that was a simple screen and roll and
kavagi always got news take a couple
steps near the basket rather quick shot
the other way there's right
we couldn't get a rebound back history
you come to put ones the other way your
dad will take it in with a lot of before
this date defense well you can say it
looks like they have a break but look at
the guys in black come flying back
outside this is a man three rebound away
[Applause]
those conference gone as the ball on
test Clark back here makes the move on
Kevin Kelly when read his chest right
the state is one eighth of nine in 16 of
18 games anything I would put up the
shot rebound handsome a very active
tonight coming off the six point game in
the round of 32 kiss / pretty good kiss
/ the team for North Dakota second team
all-big scallop last couple years
[Music]
I was a beautiful shot from outside
north
the gunk every yell away from the basket
and get the other big guy open inside
[Applause]
work on top Perkins on the side
approaching church to play the light
Thomas Perkins
nice move Perkins in basketball for the
number one seed in the West and the
number 42 state was down at halftime by
14 the Virginia Tech and one and over
time so the comebacks have been there
they need one right now to stay around a
pine they go down low with a nice dunk
by Kumud
[Applause]
keys in his wallet after the game by
Jones
it's man over three the bank elected by
Clark anymore I had written anything
took support parachute
so boy that he was just hit quite hashem
or iran in shannon's jumped out to a
13-point lead it's a three and it's good
the team on his back don't retreat
stretches there's a steel a print going
down free kitchen by fours and snort
panel crashes to the floor a recovery
here
[Applause]
Willie until he began the season with a
beautiful pea from Chile on top
be able to get into this play to me this
is a silly found the dunk by Hachi Mara
and then the reaction by Kevin Kelly
once he knew he was B there's the
contact on the backside
[Applause]
[Music]
in zaga is a winner they will play on
Saturday
[Applause]
[Music]